from pixar get ready for the movie that
made grown-ups a few Pixar is good again
and make kids everywhere say why are you
crying daddy emotions are complicated
okay inside out
Pixar built a reputation with stories
that mess with your emotions now
they've cut out the middleman and are
messing directly with the emotions
themselves in a film that teaches kids
they aren't responsible for their
actions it's just tiny people inside
their heads pushing their brain buttons
you know there's a word for that
schizophrenia
journey to San Francisco apparently the
worst place in the world San Fran's hey
maybe it's nice on the inside
congratulations San Francisco give Ron
Bates up and go inside the mind of
eleven-year-old Riley for a fresh take
on the early 90s Fox sitcom Herman's
head she's controlled by a five-member
Voltron Force of emotions but when joy
and sadness fight over her memories
their struggle will make Riley turn on a
dime between two emotional extremes
there's a word for that too bipolar I
like that time of the dinosaurs me joy
she's happy and sadness she's sad after
they're sucked away on a grand adventure
Riley's left with on your average
youtube comment section to guide her
rage fear and disgust along the way back
to headquarters joy will learn to cry
and sadness will learn to smile making
you wonder how emotions can have
emotions on top of the emotions that
they literally are but one thing's for
sure kids will have no idea what the
heck is going on experience a wildly
imaginative tour of a little girl's
brain because of this were about a guy
it would be a porno
as you tour unforgettable sights like
The Dream Factory
the imaginary boyfriend generator and
Bing and Bing bong
keep it together voice guys and Bing
bong the imaginary friend we have to
leave behind so we can grow up to be
healthy normal adults I'm sorry mr.
Spencer worth I'll never forget you as
long as I live
starring short-haired Marge Simpson I'm
blue da ba dee da ba guy purple circle
The Linde projectile vomit super meatboy
Foster's head for Imaginary Friends and
balls also not starring empathy reason
Envy tranquility courage Oh bored of
lust love or that feeling you get when
you peel dry glue off your fingers the
feels
I like tragic vampire romance island
boyband Island the bestest phase oh
great
Riley sucks now be sure to subscribe for
more honest trailers is the derivative
share requirement indexed according to
cost and percentage analysis I can't
feel my face when I'm with you but I
love it
nothing will stand in our way I will
finish what you've started the force
it's calling to you just let it in
my thumb is made of chocolate